-Nice to see you, buddy.
Good to see you.
You told me before the show,
you're very,
very skinny right now
because you're preparing
for another role.
-Yeah, yeah,
I'm a little bit light,
so I was concerned
about wearing,
you know,
such baggy clothes, but.
Yeah. Yeah, I've lost
a decent amount of weight
to play a prisoner of war.
So I'm a little bit concerned
because I think I look like --
I've seen a few photos
on the Internet of me...
-No, you look good.
-...as Slender Man.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what's so funny?
Everyone keeps -- I've been
reading articles about you,
and everyone keeps going
how tall are you?
-I know.
-They're concerned about your --
You're tall.
How tall are you?
-I'm 6'5", 197 centimeters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
-6'5".
And was that always the thing
when you were growing up
and everyone saying,
"oh, he's so tall"?
-Yeah, I was born 6'5".
-Yeah.
Wow. Amazing. Wow.
Yeah. Still delivering.
Yeah. He's still coming. Yeah.
We know it's a boy,
but we just don't know
how tall it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No, no, I mean,
I've been this big
since I was 15 or 16.
And I'm pretty sure I've been
making movies for 5 or 6 years.
So it's come as a surprise
to me now that -- Yeah.
-That's wild. Yeah.
Congratulations, by the way.
You're playing -- You're Elvis.
-Yeah, man.
-That's so fun.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Last time you were on our show,
you surprised your parents too,
and took them to a Knick game.
-Yeah, we went to the Knicks.
-Which is kind of fun
because Julius Randle is here
tonight.
But here you are.
How was the Knick game?
-[ Laughs ] My mom.
-There you are there.
-Yeah.
-Aw. Taking photos.
She's taking pics.
-It was great, man.
It was awesome.
It's always a blast. Yeah.
-Was she taking -- This
is her taking a picture of you
on the jumbotron?
-Yeah, of the big screen. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a proud mom right there.
-Yeah.
-That is a great job, mom,
I love you.
That was awesome.
Like, "That's my boy!"
-That's my mom.
-"That's my son up there."
-Yeah.
Meanwhile, I'm sat right there.
-Exactly.
She's also on the jumbotron.
Yeah, but it's not about her.
It's not about mom.
It's about you.
-Get out of here.
-Yeah. Did you meet any --
Did you meet any celebs while
you were there?
-I kind of -- I saw
Spike Lee from afar.
And I like to think
that he went like this.
-Yeah, he did, he did.
I think he did.
-You know?
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about "Priscilla."
You get to play Elvis Presley.
-Yeah.
-Is there pressure on you there
when you're playing it?
-I mean, it wasn't --
it wasn't on my list
of people to play.
It was definitely -- It was
a little bit terrifying. Yeah.
-But growing up, were you
an Elvis fan or did you...?
-No. The most I knew of Elvis
was in "Lilo and Stitch,"
that kind of...
-Wow.
-Yeah, that was my -- Yeah.
-Isn't that amazing?
-Yeah.
Which is a lot.
When you were auditioning,
did you go, "I got this,"
or you go,
like, did you nail the voice or
what did you...?
-I had -- Sofia had sent me
these sides that said Elvis,
and I kind of just was like,
"There's just no chance
that this is happening."
So I watched this clip of him
when he came back from the Army
in Germany.
And I read the lines
for like 15 minutes
and then shot two takes
and, you know,
not thinking that
it would go anywhere.
I'm pretty sure my voice
for that was like...
[ Deep vocalizing ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would have done that.
-I think it was just...
-"Hey, what's going on?"
"Jimmy, we're good. Don't even
put yourself on tape."
-But she liked it, you know.
-I mean, it's Sofia Coppola.
-Yeah.
-I mean, was that also
intimidating too, working
with -- having her direct you?
-I think it was just exciting.
Like, that was just, like,
pure bliss.
That was the only reason.
You know, the whole time
I was trying to
take it like I was making
"Blue Valentine" or something.
Just like a straight-up
relationship drama
without Elvis and Priscilla
for Sofia Coppola.
That was like the goal.
-We don't --
It focuses on the relationship
between you and Priscilla,
but you do get to wear
a couple of awesome jumpsuits.
-Yeah.
-And that's got to feel cool,
right?
-Yeah, 100%.
I mean, it was -- as soon
as you put that --
because you kind of --
you pull them on
and you zip them
from right here,
which is where all his,
you know, his energy was.
-The chi.
-Yeah. The chi was just
deeply centered and --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I understand.
-You zip it up.
It comes up
to right about here.
-It doesn't go further.
-Bow!
-Bang. Yeah. Wow. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Here we go.
Please stop doing that.
Yeah.
People have 3-D television sets
at home,
and they're getting concerned.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. -
The movie's
getting great reviews.
Congratulations on that.
I saw that it got
an eight-minute standing ovation
at the Venice Film Festival.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here's my question.
My question is what do you
do for eight minutes
when people are clapping?
Trust me, I'll never find out.
[ Laughter ]
When people clap for you --
I mean, the movie ends
and then eight minutes start?
-Yeah, basically,
the credits roll
and you're kind of waiting on
bated breath, with bated breath.
You know, are they going
to enjoy the film or not?
And then they start clapping.
And for the first 10,
15 seconds,
you know, it's wonderful.
It's nice to have the praise.
-Of course.
-And then it keeps going
and it keeps going.
-But do you look to Sofia and --
-You look at Sofia,
and she's a professional
and everyone -- and Priscilla is
standing there
looking beautiful, you know,
taking in what's deserved.
And then I kind of look
to like the press team
and they're like, "Go, go."
So you have to walk down
these steps to, like,
get them going even more,
but without, like --
-Without doing that.
-Without going like, "Get up."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to go and just
kind of be humble.
-Yeah. You're like,
"Well, I guess..."
-"I don't know. If you want to.
Yeah. I mean, we're here."
-Yeah. But I mean seven,
seven minutes is a long time,
you know?
-Gosh. Congratulations.
That's a cool moment.
You don't forget.
-Thank you. Yeah.
-By the way, it was great
to meet your sister backstage.
-Yeah. She's here somewhere.
-I love that she's here.
That's awesome. Shout-out.
That's cool.
I love that you stay close
to your family. I love that.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jacob Elordi
in "Priscilla."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Prints take away
from your look.
-Oh, it's like a forest.
-I like this one.
-Solid suits you better.
And I hate brown.
Reminds me of the army.
♪♪
[ Indistinct conversation ]
Mm.
Black hair and more eye makeup.
Make your eyes stand out more.
-Mm-hmm.
-4:00, boys. We got to go.
Barbecue's waiting. Let's go.
-Yeah, bud, you had it
even down.
You had everything
down to a tee.
-Thank you, man.
-Jacob Elordi, everybody.
"Priscilla" is in theaters
November 3rd.
More with Jacob
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.